Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to Minecraft.
Now I know it's been a long time since the last time I played this game
but that's kind of a good thing
because there's been an incredible number of updates to the game
like, eleven full updates to the game since the last time I played it.
So, I thought the best way to get into this
Uh, which is going to be a very long term series
I'm probably gonna do, maybe 100 parts of this before I'll get through all the new stuff,
but I thought the best place to start
would be to just create a new world
call it what I wanna call it
I'll call it "Markiplier's Fun House"
And then just get into it
and start exploring from the ground up.
Because sometimes you just gotta get your hands dirty when you're playing a new game
and really start fresh
because what you think you know, can get in the way of what you will discover
in the world.
So
I uuh...
Man it's been a while since I played this
It's been a while since I've been back in the Minecraft world and...
Ya know I gotta say it's good to be back
It's good to be uhh...
It's good to be back into this whole environment
And one of the things that I like the most about Minecraft
has always been the music and the sound and the ambiance
because where it doesn't have graphics
is where it might
have some more experience to discover
And as usual, this hasn't changed.
I know you guys are wondering like,
"Ah man, is the very basic building blocks of the game different?"
The answer is nooo
*heh*
And uh..
You still punch wood to get it
I don't know, I don't know
It's charming at this point
Just the fact that you're slamming your bony fists into a hunk of wood
And hoping that
it'll - It'll -it'll
smash to pieces before your.. your brittle skeleton does
But you know
You just do what you can with what you got
And if you've forgotten
Oh, there's my little guy
I still get an achievement for taking inventory
But, it's, it's all the same
You just craft up a storm
Oh
Man I'm getting ahead of myself
I totally forgot how to play
You gotta make wood first ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
And then make a table out of that!
because, once you have the crafting table
You're still able to make all of the other basic fundamental building blocks
of this entire game.
Because it starts from the very
You know
Early stages of what you're supposed to do
And then grows
Into something even bigger and better
Now
You may be seeing
I don't know what thi-i-iis is *glitching*
Is this a shield *glitch* or something? I have no idea
*glitching* No idea, n-n-no idea
*muffled* -weird, I don't even know where to being with this stuff
*computer screeching*
*infinite blue screen*
*start-up sounds*
H̨͇̓̎͋a͎̼͐̀v͙̻̜͚̞̗͚̱̔͆͑̆̍͢i͇͇͙͈͚͍͆ͦ̊̓n͉̼̫̥̱ͭ͛̋̃g̛̣̮͉̺̝̯͔̹͍̃ͯ̉̊̕͟ ̪̮͋̎ͮ̐͊̓͘͝s̪̃̋̏̋͂ͨȯ̸̧̳͕͖̻̈͊͜m̜͍̍̃̃͐̀͘ë̷́̇̂ͨ̐̂ͮ̄҉̛͉̤͍̳̱̪͇̮̣ ̴̟̭͖̙̌͑̋ͣͣt̮̲̻̝̠̪̂ͬ̎ͥ̂ͨͣ͟ͅe̺̲͔̲͕̳͈̓ͮ̓͑̃͘͠c̸̡̲̮̱̬̓̈̊́h̶͍͙͚͇ͣ͋͞n͚͚̫ͧ͂̀͢i̸̞̔̍͊͞c̪͙͚͎̳̜͛ͫ́ͨ̓̎̏̎́a̷̡̟̹̯̫̳͂̓̈͋ͫ͂͜l͆̈ͯ̿̈́ͬ͏̵̜̰̞ ̙̭̮͈̩̰̣̟̬ͫ͜d̨ͧͦ̎͏̷͖͔̟̪͇̪į̵̢̬͙̪̩͊ͫ̆͐͂ͨͮ̌f̼̮̐ͬ̾͋ͯͧ̀͑̍f̴̘̙̟̥̤͛͢i̢̼͙͉͓̓̽̀ͩ͛̀c̨̜͖͇͑̐ͨ́͝ͅu̬̳̲̣͈̘͇͑͐ͫ̀ͧ̾̽͢ͅl͚̘̭̝͉͈͓͔ͯ͐̈́̊̏̀t̹̳̯̥̩͋̓̅͌̅ͅi̠̺̗͇̽͆ͨ̾͢e͌̽҉͓̖͠s̊͂҉̪̹͎͖͉̬̼͖̀?ͩ͒̉̀́͏̶̤͓̟ͅͅ
W̡͙͓̖̟͙͐ͭ͂̚o̮̟̐ͥ̂̇ͦͫͩ̋̕ū̟͚̠̬͗ͧ̇l̲̭͍̺̙̠͚̦̻̑͋̄̓̒̀͟͞d͖̥̰̯͈͈̘ͤ̔͛ͮ̒ ̵̨̢̺̥̖ͦy̭̫̗̩͚̆̈́͆̇ͥ͠ō̴̡̖͙̗̽͋̀̈ͬ̏͑͢ù͍̄̾ͨ̋͟͟ ̨̲̟̯̾͂͡l̘̤͔̰͚͓̍̌̊ͦͩͤͨi̸̙̼̟̠̤͎̣ͨ̋ͦ̚̕k͚͈̪̃̃e͉͍̺̹̣̳ͪͬ̾̀̄̿͆͜ ̭̰̮͔͙̘̼̾̾̾ͩ͝͡m̲ͩ͋ë̷̛̩̫͖̞̬̳͖͕͊ ̴̵̨̳̟̬͕͖̘̔̂͂͊ͦ̇ͅt̼̻̳̟̭̭͓͈̐̍̎̆ō̶͔͚͇͎̕͢ ̢̺͉̻͈͎̳͈͇̺̈̔̔̀́ͫͥs̡̹̩͓̖̦͓̰̱ͫͩ̈̓̏͋͊̕͟e̛͓͈͚͆̎ͫ̌͟a͎̭͚̩̪̤̮͌ͥͪ̌̀͝ŕ̸̶̻̥̏ͨ̊̍͒̎̍͡c͒̍ͭ͒̓ͩͩ̚̕͏̠̪̬̝h̟͔̫̝̾ͭ̅̏ͥ̓̽̐ ̴̭̣͚̎́̆ͬ͊ͩḟ̯̺̊ͫ̾o͎ͮ̌̓ͪ̂ͬ̿́r̬̟̳̮̪͔͚̩̓͑̆̀͢ ̰͙̟͚̪͈͛ͤ̾ͨ̾͛͘͠a̧̱̱̐ͧ̌̋ͯͧ̚͞ ̺̜͖͙͇̩̽̿ṡ͔̠̤̠̣̰̜͋̎͌ͮͬ̍o̮̼̅̃̌̉̒͛l̴̷̗̘̳̭̩̩ͦ̅ͬ̌̚̕ͅų̮̪̆͛́͝ț̴̷̨̽ͬ̉̀̅̂̀͂̔ị͇̳̬͇̹̊̑̄̈́ͨͤ͆ͅö̖͓̦ͣ̏̿̐̎̈́͝n̵̥̣̩̳̟̠̩̰ͧ̈́̌̀͌̚ ̡̩̪͈͓̭͛͗ͬ͑ͅṭ̶͓̤͕̣̱̤͇̌͐̌͞o̢̢̺͓̣̞ͩͧ̌͢ ̢̹̗̼̩̱̬͑̐͟͜yͬͮͨ̐͏̥̻̟̩o͓͖̠̯͖̿̐̂͞͝u̟̟̮͕͍̺̤̺̓̂͛ṟ̨̱͔ͮͦ͟ ͚͈̻̝̩̬̫͓̂̇͐̓ͥ͛̋͒͠p̡̜ͪͥ̓ͫ̄͋ͬ͗͞-̹̱̭̠̼̲̈͆͌p̪̩̮̺̣̔̌ͨͫ́͝ͅr̫̙͙̳̒͌̕͘͞-͍͚͇̝̩͉̻ͣ̓̀̒̑ͫ̌͠r̎ͭ͞҉̨̥̗̯̤͔̩̹̟o͎̹͗̾̽̈́ͧ̔͆b̨̧̟͐̃͗ͬͨ̈́͝ͅl̗̟̙͇̺͍͔͊͜e̢̖͖͙̟͓͒́̐̇̆̀͞m͍̫̍̒̔?̡̨̩̣̙̪͓̱͍ͤ̽ͩ̔ͪͬ̍͢;̧͓̣͖͚͍͚̜̒ͪ͛ͥ́͠ͅ
M̻͇̙̺̬͍̟̟̮ͩ̍̾̍̇͐y̹̦̻̬̣̻̓͂̅͋ ̮̩̥̟̞͓͒͆̏̐̐̽̆͞p̣̙̝̒̈́̒ͭ̄ͥ-̢̛̲͎͊͒̏̈̈́̅͜p̾̋͊͏̡̨̜̥͎̙̣̣̼-̧͇̜͓͕͕̱̖̎ͣ̆͗̚͠p̖̜͆̐͌̆̚͘r̸͈͇ͩͥ̐ͦ͊̌̑̚̕i̴̛͓̬̍̅̽̈́ͤ͠m̝͚̲̞̖̮̆ͥ̈̋ͥả̗̺̣̹̳̹̣ͯͅr̴̶̨̠͎̦̓̉y̹̞͎̼̞̥̳̙͛ͬ͢͞ ͉̫̱̹̄ͤ͊̽̉̂͒ǒ̯̝̱̻̝͖̹̯͛ͩ̌̀ͭ̚̚b̡ͮ͗ͣͮͬ͟҉̜̺̲̳͇͎̙͓j̨̨̪̠͖̗̰̹̃ͣ̏̀ẽ̳̮͆ͩ͢c̋̊̄͢͏͚̞̯̬̣ͅͅt͍͖̔͒̋ͣ́i̥̙̩͔̮͍͎͇̓ͤ͆̐v̤͍̐͂̇̀̈́́ͮ̉ȅ̡̱͙̲͉̦̮̣̮̦̆͗ͬ͑͞ ͙̮̜̳̾̏ͩ̚̕i̷̫͎̼̤̥̟̭̓͆̀͡s͓͚̭͓̦̄͊ͤ̏̔ ̣͉̤̣̠͚̇̂̓t̫̘͂̾̃̓̔̈̑o͑̽̃̚͝͏̥̬͍̠̥̠ ̙̝̓ͤ̃͟a̻̩̙ͧ͆ͮ͗ͣ̿̈͜ͅn̎͆ͯ̋̊͘҉͈̺̙͓̮͓͚̖s̱̮̰̜̹̫̼̅ͦ̈́̀͑̆́w̧͖͖̻̫͚̝ͭͯ̽ȩ͙̟̜̜̱ͨ̉ͧ̒̎ͪͮ̾ȓ͑̆ͬ̏̏̔͏͓̝͓ ̡̬̭͈̲̿ͥͥ̆̊̊q͓͇͉̩͋͆͋ͥ͘͘u̶̥͆͂̓ͥͨ͝é̆̂̐ͤ́̿҉͍̝s̄ͬ̅͆̔ͫ҉̶̜̭̫̼̦͚͙͈̯t̝̥̬̮̄͞i̠̭̺͇ͨ̅͘͢ö̥̤͔̼ͪ̈́̍ͫͣ͢n̨̛̖̗͛͛ͥ̽̒̉ͅs̬̝̗͎̲̭̗̘̓̄ͩ ̨͖̰̟͆ͤͣͩͅa̰̦̓̓͌̌ͭ͆̈͒s̡̤̼̻̮͍ͥͧ͐̈̐͊̍͘ ̫̪͙͎̞̠ͯͩ̋͊ͮ͝q̨̜̝̱̹̃ͧ͆͗u̳̹̫̪͎̳ͩ̐ͨ͘͜ͅì̫͍̟̼̥̣̪̅ͬ͛̄͝c̡̳̒̾k̷͚̦̖̪̰͒͒̋ͪ̓l̵͉͔͕̺̩͓̀̑̿ͥ̉ͮ̾̓͌ͅy̹͓̩͗̃͘͟ ̖̝͎̫̳̥͂͗̐͑̀́͂ͧͅa̸̠̖̤͇̰̎͊͑͆̾̆̂͋͠sͫ̓̈̔͝͏̷͇͔͙͓̜̖̭̤̠ ̝̯̲̪̻͔̰͑͢p̲̤̆̓̃̓o̸̪̥̘͎̜̦̦ͣ͐ͦ̎͆͂͆s̳̝͙̝͍̓͟ͅs̘̯̹̐̈́̓͘͟͝ĭ̵͚̦̭̬͖̋͒̿́͢b̀ͨ̑̋̿̃͏̪̺̱̯̫̦͜l̸̼͎̎̒ͪ͒͊̆̓̚͘͜ḙ͓͖̳͆͛̅̒ͦ̆̒;̵̛̲̮̠̤͎͕̏̏͒ͦ͗͜
M̻͉̳̙̮͙̻̪͚̍ͬ̓̆̿̈́y̖̟͂̏̃ͩ͒̇̕ ̶̤̭̦͗̉̾̾̎̃̏s͊͆̊̌͛̏ͭ̇̊͏̷̖͓̺͔͍͔̥̭̼e̟̪͓̩͇̠͖͕ͭ͋̽̀̒̾͠c̷̺̞̱̪̭͕̘̰͈͗̍ͣ̐̇́̚͝ǒ̵̵͕̬̘̯ͤ̆̊̃̀n͍̥̫͚̻̰ͯ̿̀́ḋ̷͈̥̝̻͆̑ͮȁ͛͛̉̄̃͂ͩ҉͍̥r͌ͬ͏̼̻͙͔͢ý̸̥̼̮̜̹̟̻͇̊̓ͥ͆̚̕͝ ̵͖͖̪͚͖͔̒͟͟o̗̥͓̝͚̖̩ͯͦ̌̒̅̒͛̈͢b̰͙̽͊ͫ́͡ĵ̱̪ͤ̍ͭͯͅ-̶̖̟̑̓ͯ̊̆e̶͚̙̙̦̬̭̍̋-̡̗͉ͮ͒ͭ̂e̢̘̲̲͚ͫ͛͆̈́ͩͩͫ͝͝c̬͇ͤ̒ͨ͒͌̎́͗t̵̺̣̝͇͈̪̜̙ͬ͂̋̀̍͗̾i̛͔͚̪͖̓ͬͫ͘ͅvͯͧ̍ͪͯ̏͋͂͡ͅḛ͚̝͉͛͌̉͐̽̊ͧ͢ ̛̼̰͓̃͗̔̆ͦ̓͡͡ͅi̷̪͖̜̪͕̲ͭ͑͆̍͝s̩̮̠̤͑̏ ̞͔̉ͨ͊̇͢t̖͚̠͛ͣ͆͞ͅo̷̱͈͔̖̹͕̠̬ͬ́̿ͩͭͧ͑ͧ ̦̞͇̝̰̫̉d͙̲̞̮̏̋̅̐ͨ̀͑̊͜͝e̞̒ͩ͌̃s̳̳̳̖̹̺͗͒ͤͮ̌ͯͨ̀t̟̰̂ͫ͂̊ͯ̒r͂͂ͬ̐ͬ́҉̤o͕̘͊̏̃̕ÿ̸̥̟͎͚̏ͪ ̯̂̄̒̌̓ͅm̢̭̖̜̌̚͝a̧̬̥̤̠̮̼̼̽̍̌ͭ̈̄ñ͉̖̖̺̘̲͜ͅͅk̠̬̔i̴̴̛̠̩̲̯̤̲ͦ̅̒̈́̓nͤͩ͌҉̟̭͕̦̲͈̀d̨͖̦̱̯̺̞͎̍̅͋̏̉̎ͅ